what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters resolve the flesh off
your bones are you ready to dive deep
into Disney's Strange World we've got
exclusive content from the animators
voice actors and co-directors to help
you dissect everything this elaborate
world has to offer this is gonna be
awesome number one the creators Dove
deep into all the classic adventure
movies specifically Jules Verne films
were a big inspiration for the director
Don Hall I did a lot of research into
early Adventure novels which is joyous
research as you can imagine we are
talking Raiders of the Lost Ark 20 000
Leagues Under the Sea King Kong and
Jurassic Park did you recognize any
references to those Classics he's
awesome he is not awesome number two a
lot of thought went into the colors of
the world when the movie first starts
out the characters are on a farm with
the main color scheme being blue and
green the animators had to make sure
that one once they entered Strange World
the colors really popped off the screen
it had to be no question that they were
in a completely different world in a
strange world we have every color except
green and probably Brown and some
neutrals in order to achieve this
consistently vibrant look they had to
divide all the scenes by color this
sequence is more magenta next sequence
is more yellow number three coloring the
world and designing the world were a
completely different ball game have them
you know really kind of Define the
designs the rules of the world and then
we fill in all of the blanks they would
then design all of the objects models
and shapes before adding color and
texture even to the point where the
world is usually too big and we can't
build it all they would then use a set
extension to fill in the rest of the
world all the way out to the horizon
skunk I know I'm happy too number four
this story pulled at everyone's
heartstrings we're the cast of Disney's
Strange World Gabrielle Union was drawn
to her character because she felt that
her motivations as a mother were
extremely relatable it's a very loving
you know mother and wife I brought that
to the role the producer Roy Conley said
he'd never seen a cast so dedicated and
devoted to bringing a story to life from
day one from the day that Jake came in
Dennis Gabrielle and jibuki they all
invested in the story there's 450 people
who have touched this film and these
four did such an amazing job in terms of
bringing these characters to life we're
the place we love danger number five
there would be a fair share of
ad-libbing though Gabrielle Union is no
stranger to film this was her first huge
animated role she describes working on
this film as a dream come true one of
the biggest factors in that was the free
Freedom they gave her in the booth to be
given freedom to contribute was great it
was just easy just easy top to bottom
number six or more like the characters
becoming the actors suddenly my
character has dimples suddenly my
character's like boy bye what the
animators kept a close eye on all of the
voice actors facial expressions and body
language to the point that they truly
did become one and the same at the end
of the process they're putting all of
our mannerisms and our facial
expressions into the character number
seven giving an accurate representation
of her character was huge for Gabrielle
Union not only did the animators take
little things from her personality and
put them into her character but they
created a totally accurate physical
representation of Meridian seeing the
hair texture of Meridian and the curls
that was huge her having very
Afrocentric features and her having a
shape hips that was awesome the
animation team is incredibly diverse and
they really wanted this movie to
represent the world we actually live in
we all want to appear in the world and
we are in the world number eight the
creators had to think so outside of the
box it broke our brains but but we were
all recovering from it but I think it's
uh it's just paying off they wanted
everything in this movie to be like
nothing anyone has ever seen before
which we're sure you can imagine is not
an easy task they also had to be careful
that they weren't distracting from the
film's characters it's most important to
honor those relationships within the
scene but there are times when the
characters are astonished by what
they're seeing that's when we can really
show off this wondrous environment which
is the most important aspect of all of
it number nine one director is a Disney
veteran and the other is new to the
scene Don Hall and qigwin worked on
strange worlds together both pulling
from their own experiences with their
fathers though you would think they
would Clash on concepts with Qui being
relatively new to Disney Animation they
had a lot in common both of them really
liked the concept that when growing up
you didn't want to be anything like your
father but after becoming fathers
themselves they've realized they are
more like their dads than they imagined
those are kind of almost elements that
we didn't realize as teenagers are some
of our favorite elements about ourselves
number 10 the directors knew from the
very beginning that Ethan was going to
be a gay character it's an aspect of
Ethan and just one of the many things
that makes him who he is historically
throughout Disney films and animation
the lgbtq characters were never fully
described as such this movie decided to
change that it's just accepting it as a
normal reflection of our reality number
11 a lot was taken from the actors
movements in the booth yeah no props
yeah like the the the stay on the music
stand you have a few things you can use
though there weren't any props in the
voiceover Booth the actors still used
what they could to convey the movements
being shown on screen at one point Jake
Gyllenhaal had to act out picking up
Splat but he had no idea what Splat even
looked like yeah it was like Wow and so
I did it and now that was the way
splatters picked up in the movie number
12. the family's three-legged dog a cool
anecdote about Legend is that he's named
after Bernie Madison who pushed really
hard for Legends to be in the film he
was honored as an inductee of the Disney
Legends program in 2008 and is
officially the longest serving employee
of the Walt Disney Company
number 13 depending on where the
characters are the sound is completely
different everything in strange world is
more than meets the eye you would think
that something is just a regular form of
plant life but it's not it's alive it
also probably makes some sort of odd
sound that the creative team had to
brainstorm in a meeting we would have
loved to be a fly on the wall for
[Music]
[Applause]
number 14 we told you before how
involved the cast was I think the thing
about these movies that makes them so
fun is the energy that we give to them
Jake Gyllenhaal in particular was very
devoted to his character Searcher and
told the directors that if he was going
to do it he wanted to be super involved
you probably don't understand a word I'm
saying of course I understand you so
involved in fact that he would actually
have them rewrite part of the script if
he didn't think it was true to his
character really would be a big part of
creating the story and they were right
and it was just done with so much love
Roy Conley talks to BuzzFeed about his
experience working with Jake Searcher
wouldn't do this he would say so then
we'd send it back to the writers and
they'd rewrite the whole segments it was
just a loving environment and it's all
in the movie it's all it really is all
in the movie number 15 she was actually
hesitant to accept the role of Callisto
Mao we're not sure but avalonia's future
depends on us finding out it took three
meetings and a whole lot of character
development to get Lucy on board during
her second meeting with Roy Conley she
decided that the character just wasn't
her and she wasn't interested in being
part of the film Roy and the rest of the
team really wanted her involved so they
went off and developed the character
into more of an adventurer as well as
the president of avalonia after that she
was happy to accept the role it's really
involved and I think it really gives you
a better idea of how things are done how
things are produced and created strange
world is definitely a unique
collaborative and diversely represented
movie to step onto the scene of Disney
Animation what were you most excited to
find out about let us know in the
comments
foreign